hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called The
Machine spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie is set in a
dystopian future where the Western
countries are in a cold war with China
which forces them into the deepest
recession recorded in history the scene
cuts to a military-based laboratory
where Dr McCarthy runs some tests on a
soldier named Paul Dawson after
inserting a brain implant it turns out
that Paul had died in action two years
ago but is now resurrected by the brain
implant however after the cognitive test
McCarthy is disappointed with the
results and argues with his assistant
about terminating Paul as they argue
Paul picks up a pen without them
noticing and abruptly hugs McCarthy from
behind startled McCarthy orders Paul to
sit back down but the latter suddenly
stabs him in the chest McCarthy bleeds
all over the computer and tries to shut
down Paul's brain implant but to no
avail after this Paul relentlessly stabs
McCarthy's assistant to death and also
takes down a security guard then he
picks up the guard's rifle and is about
to finish off McCarthy when he suddenly
realizes his mistake and lowers his gun
the next second additional security
arrives and shoots Paul dead the scene
then cuts to some time in the future
where McCarthy's Stab Wound is healed
and he heads into work there he conducts
the Turing test for artificial
intelligence machines made by aspiring
candidates with the aim of giving them a
prize if the AI passes the Turing test
is a test to examine a machine's ability
to exhibit intelligent behaviors
equivalent to that of humans McCarthy
then tests two different eyes but they
both fail and he ends his day with
frustration at home it's revealed that
McCarthy has a daughter named Mary who
suffers from Rhett syndrome which is a
neurological disorder that impairs
speech and leads to intellectual
disabilities the next day in another
interview a researcher named Ava
presence her latest development in Ai
and explains that her machine gathers
information from daily conversations as
she and the Machine chat every day
curious McCarthy conducts the Turing
test and is impressed with the potential
that the AI
so after the test he complements Ava for
the impressive Ai and asks her for the
configuration of her program however she
asks for the prize first McCarthy then
tries to convince Ava to do research
under his guidance as it's revealed that
there was no prize and that he actually
needed a skilled researcher for his work
on the contrary Ava is skeptical about
McCarthy's work and questions what he
works on it's then revealed that the
ministry of defense is putting forward
all of its finances towards McCarthy's
projects Ava immediately suspects that
he makes weapons for the government but
McCarthy insists that he makes
intelligent machines hearing this Ava
finally agrees to the job and on her
first day she pulls up to the entrance
of the military base where she sees Mrs
Dawson all of a sudden the woman lunges
toward Ava's car and claims that the
military has her son the guards quickly
pull her away but Ava reacts to the
guard's indecency towards the old woman
this prompts another guard to restrain
Ava and as a result she is arrested on
her first day at work sometime later
McCarthy bails her out and informs her
that Paul Dawson was killed in action
two years ago and that his mother is
delusional later at the military base
McCarthy shows off around while a female
cyborg named Surrey observes them
through the security cameras it turns
out that the security guards outside and
inside the base are also cyborgs and
they initiate security protocols as
McCarthy and Ava head down into the
underground facilities Ava notices a
scar on the guard's head and McCarthy
reveals that they are soldiers who had
brain trauma injuries and that it is
where the brain implants are planted the
aim of the implant being is to reanimate
the physically impaired and brain-dead
soldiers so that they can be used in war
but for some reason the implants render
the cyborgs completely mute several
months after the implant surgery however
unbeknownst to anyone the cyborgs have a
completely different communication
system which they keep a secret for
themselves McCarthy takes Ava into his
laboratory office where she meets Surrey
and the director of the ministry of
Defense Thompson then she meets a
soldier named James whose arms are
amputate he prepares to try out his new
prosthetic arms which exhibit qualities
such as being bulletproof bomb proof
having superhuman strength and the
ability to adapt its skin to match the
host's body Ava is astonished by the
development and out of the blue James
asks to hold her hand so he can have the
pleasure of touching another person
again Ava happily agrees but all of a
sudden James pulls her away from the
others and Whispers for help he also
secretly mentions area 6 to her the
following day McCarthy asks a series of
questions to Ava in order to record her
brain activity to the supercomputer in
his lab Ava then suddenly questions him
about area 6 and McCarthy describes it
as the place where the injured soldiers
are being treated the next day she
manages to sneak into area 6 unnoticed
where she looks over a glass window and
sees a heavily guarded Camp however
moments later Ava is found by the cyborg
guards and she flees the scene without
saying a word later as McCarthy
continues to map her brain activity he
lashes out at Ava and sternly warns her
to avoid causing trouble in the meantime
Surrey shows Thomas surveillance footage
of Ava using the quantum computer to
access restricted Files about Paul
Dawson and area 6. one day McCarthy and
Ava drive back from work together there
he finally tells Ava the truth and it
turns out that he plans to use the
implant technology to treat his
daughter's Rhett syndrome along the road
they come across Mrs Dawson crying in
the middle of the road and Ava suggests
that they take her home so she
approaches Mrs Dawson only to find out
that it is actually a Chinese imposter
impersonating her the sheinson
immediately stabs Ava in the stomach and
knocks McCarthy out simultaneously
Thomas receives a live video
transmission from the Chinese man which
shows Ava getting shot multiple times
it's then revealed that it was Thomas
who ordered the hit on her the day after
Ava's murder Thomas claims to McCarthy
that the Chinese want to delay their
implant project and in order to do so
they thought of killing Ava who was part
of the project McCarthy however is not
convinced as he was untouched in the
attack grieved by the loss of Ava he and
insist that they use her brain to scan
the new cyborg whom they name machine
after the machine is built it looks
exactly like Ava and turns out to be
more human than McCarthy hoped it to be
to make machine exhibit signs of fear
one of the scientists dresses up as a
clown and jump scares her frightened
machine Jabs her finger inside the
scientist's head killing him instantly
McCarthy is furious and reprimands
machine for killing the man and orders
her to not hurt anyone machine genuinely
apologizes and shortly after showing
guilt she shuts down a few hours later
McCarthy continues to try to fix machine
but to no avail after he leaves the
female cyborg Surrey walks into his lap
and approaches machine all of a sudden
machine grabs Suri's arm and the
latter's face begins to Glow machine
then mutters something important in the
Cyborg's language to Surrey before she
leaves the next day in his lab McCarthy
is relieved to see machine functioning
normally just then he gets a phone call
from a doctor revealing that his
daughter Mary is in terrible condition
McCarthy decides to leave immediately
but machine insists him to stay she even
grabs and squeezes his hand with full
force hurting him this agitates McCarthy
and when he starts screaming she finally
lets him go enraged he reprimands
machine and orders her to never use her
strength against people for her own
benefit in the next scene McCarthy
arrives at the hospital where the doctor
explains that Mary's case has become
very severe and she has to undergo
surgery afterwards McCarthy goes to see
Mary and starts to download her facial
and brain scans so that he can use the
data to make an AI of Mary if she passes
away meanwhile at the laboratory
Thompson enters machines room and
instructs her to download a secret file
which was pre-installed in her system as
Sheen obliges and it turns out that she
is now fluent in different languages and
has acquired various combat skills
afterwards Thompson takes machine into a
room where a Chinese man is kept captive
he then brainwashes machine claiming
that the Chinese man had killed her
mother and will kill McCarthy next the
following day McCarthy enters his lab
and finds machine sitting under his
table without any clothes on unaware of
what happened he tries to comfort her
and finds out that she killed the China
Furious McCarthy confronts Thompson in
his office where they argue about the
true purpose of machine McCarthy argues
that it is more than just a soldier and
has evolved into a living being capable
of human emotions while Thompson scoffs
at his claims he thinks that machine has
no emotions and feelings at all later
McCarthy informs machine of the
situation and she is surprisingly ready
to do anything that is deemed necessary
all of a sudden McCarthy is called by
Mary's doctor who tells him that the
little girl unfortunately didn't make it
during the surgery this devastates
McCarthy and he breaks down in tears a
few days pass by and machine continues
her military training after Mary's
burial McCarthy finally returns back to
the lab machine sympathizes with
McCarthy and instructs him to look
closer to find his answers so upon
inspecting machine's eyes he shockingly
finds the proof that he needs so he
rushes into Thomas office and shows
proof of spontaneous integrated
information
also known as Consciousness that is
found in machines program code however
Thompson orders him to remove the part
making machine conscious as he thinks
that it is dangerous McCarthy refuses
the order after being cheated and lied
to by Thompson it's then revealed that
the latter had deleted all the copies of
Mary's brain scans he has the final
remaining copy which he uses as leverage
against McCarthy later McCarthy breaks
the bad news to machine and explains
that the procedure must be done in order
to avoid losing her he claims that she
is his only remaining daughter
surprisingly machine complies and
believes in his decision so in the
operating room McCarthy operates on
machine and takes out the chip which
causes her to suddenly lose her
Consciousness later in Thompson's office
it turns out that he has deleted Mary's
brain scans for security purposes this
enraged McCarthy and suddenly he is
restrained and stunned by the guards
before being thrown into a cell over the
course of the next few days machine
develops into a very skillful killer one
day to verify her commitment to Thompson
McCarthy is dry dragged into a room and
machine is ordered to shoot him in the
head with no hesitation machine pulls
the trigger but the magazine is empty
much to his relief simultaneously as
scientist finds out that the chip that
McCarthy had removed was not machine's
Consciousness but was actually a battery
for her GPS system Thompson begins to
panic and immediately puts the whole
facility into lockdown while machine and
Ty's McCarthy she then reveals that the
cyborg guards including Surrey have been
planning to retaliate against humans for
a long time and this is their chance on
the other hand Thompson enters the
termination codes for the cyborgs and
they begin to shut down one by one
however Surrey overrides his access
before he can kill the rest elsewhere
machine proceeds to fight through the
human guards while McCarthy makes his
way to the quantum computer to destroy
it there he meets up with the arm
amputee James and almost gets killed but
fortunately he manages to head to the
quantum computer and initiate
self-destruct which finishes off James
immediately afterwards Thompson shoots
and wounds sir but machine Corners him
in his office she then slowly approaches
Thompson who begs for his life however
she shows no mercy and suddenly crushes
his skull killing him afterwards machine
downloads Mary's brain scans and flees
the military base with McCarthy the
scene then cuts to the Future in a
beautiful field where McCarthy talks to
an AI version of Mary through his phone
thanks for watching subscribe and hit
that like button to help our Channel
grow turn on the notifications so you
won't miss any of our new videos